not long after the release of the
division
in 2016 it was announced that there is
an action feature film adaptation in
development
starring jack gillenhall and jessica
chastain
but over time this seemed to fall off
the radar with no updates over the
following years
most fans had come to the conclusion
that the movie had been shelved
however out of the blue five years after
the initial announcement
we were given news that not only is the
film currently being worked on
but it's being led by a new director who
just happens to be
a huge fan of the franchise
originally i wasn't going to talk about
this because it was plastered all over
social media and i figured a lot of
people were probably already quite aware
but i was still getting a ton of
questions in the youtube comments which
started to highlight that
not everyone is as nerdy as me checking
out all the latest media updates
and following all the social circles so
that plus the fact that my channel is
heavily invested in the story and
setting of the division universe
it probably makes sense that i cover
this
when the idea of the movie was first
announced david leach was put in place
as the director but over time he was
forced to step into a producer role due
to scheduling conflicts
and this is where rawson thurber took
the reins
gerber's most recent work includes the
action comedy thriller red notice
where he wrote and directed the film
starring dwayne johnson
and ryan reynolds due to be released
sometime in 2021
previously he's worked on other movies
such as skyscraper central intelligence
dodgeball and weather millers
shortly after it was announced on
twitter day one community member and
host of the echocast podcast
born diesel asked if thurber would like
to have a chat on a show
and i gather much to born surprise he
accepted
thurber has been a day one fan of the
division franchise and actually waited
for three hours in line to watch it at
e3
2013 when it was first announced he
spoke about how the first time he saw
the game his jaw was on the floor
the attention to detail the atmosphere
the impressive graphics
and the dark and gritty feel around a
christmas that was never able to happen
since the release of the division one
thurber himself has invested many
thousands of hours of game time into the
franchise
now obviously there is only so much he
could talk about regarding the story
but he did make some interesting
comments on the parts of the division
story that has motivated the direction
he'd like to take the movie
the concept of the division one
particularly appeals to him because it's
fundamentally about doing something good
getting the power back on getting food
to people and helping others
he goes on to talk about how the
division is not a post-apocalyptic
story it's a mid-crisis story while
society is bouncing on a knife's edge
it's up to us to save it there are also
a lot of questions
like what do we owe each other in a
society in a lawless state where there
is no
external force it's basically up to your
own moral compass to make the choice
whether you want to help or become a
part of the chaos unfolding around you
what would you do when everything falls
apart
another unique aspect is that the
division agents are essentially normal
people
they come from all walks of life but
when that watch is activated
they pack their things and run towards
the danger
this adds a powerful supporting theme
for the story
obviously there will be a lot of action
shooting and taking cover
but what it's really about is supporting
those who can't support themselves
so in case it wasn't obvious by now the
movie will be set in new york
and will be based around the same time
period as the division one
and before you ask yes the hunters will
be making an appearance
one of the first things people talk
about when they hear of the division
becoming a film
is that movie adaptations based on video
games don't exactly have the best
reputation
more often than not they either aren't
particularly good or they don't perform
well
and thurber is well aware of this but he
goes on to explain
about how the division is a little
different to other films that have been
made in the past
firstly although there are a number of
well-known characters like feylau
benitez keener etc
the main character the player agent you
play as yourself
you experience the division as yourself
he is also very adamant on the fact that
the way you experience a video game is
very different to the way you experience
a film
and that you should never try to make a
movie that feels like a video game
or vice versa a video game like a movie
thurber's plan is to approach the movie
by telling a story
that is set within this world that feels
like a division story
and is about those characters and their
journey
there will be a ton of easter eggs
weapons and shooting as this is very
important
but the story and the characters need to
be front and center
in saying that thuba has stated that the
skills must be included
that they are a huge iconic part of the
division there may not be room for all
of the skills but the ones mentioned
were sycamines
pulse turrets both flame and assault and
a hive
he seems quite passionate about this
aspect in fact in his words he said
what's so awesome about the division is
the tech i'm going to be shameless about
using as much of it as i can
so it'll be quite interesting to see how
these turn out
for a movie based on a video game to
succeed it needs to appeal to an
audience far wider than the player base
itself
thurber is taking the opportunity to
tell a story that's fresh
and feels of the game but at the same
time isn't just
the game he wants the story and movie to
lean on the fundamental questions
of what do we owe each other in society
what are you willing to do
to save what you love how will we help
each other during these times
are you a selfish person or a selfless
person in these moments of crisis
the movie is currently in the scripting
phase there was a previous draft but
thurber had a very specific idea of what
he wanted to do
so he started from scratch with writer
alan shenman
once the script is done and approved the
pre-production of the movie will begin
if all goes well they're hoping to start
shooting by the end of 2021
jake gyllenhaal and jessica chastain are
very focused and passionate on this
movie and are pushing to start the
shooting as soon as possible
so fingers crossed we'll be seeing some
more progress by the end of the year
rawson thurber described his ambitions
behind this film as an attempt to show
an exciting and harrowing
story full of jeopardy heart and a touch
of humor to top it off
a big thank you to born diesel for not
only being more than happy with me using
the information from his ecocast
interview
but for reaching out on behalf of the
division community to have a chat about
the intentions towards something that
many of us hold very close to our hearts
please check out borne's channel and
show out some engie and love
spam those comments for me you won't
find too many other people as dedicated
as him when it comes to the division
franchise
i'll also have a link to the full 40
minute interview in the description
also if for some weird reason that
rawson watches this video
thank you i'm glad that this movie has
been put in the hands of someone who's
obviously a fan of the game
admittedly i always thought the division
story would make a decent movie
however i wasn't particularly
enthusiastic about it
but now with a member of this odd little
community at the helm
i'm very excited to see the outcome no
pressure
anyway thank you very much for watching
everyone i hope you found this
informative
and i'll catch you in the next one
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
uh